punto en común es un experimento social
que reúne a personas de creencias
opuestas las discusiones podrían
contener opiniones que nacen de la
desinformación recuerde consultar
expertos y ser crítico al momento de
formar sus propias creencias por favor
recuerde a la humanidad de cada
participante y no olvide la empatía
soy una mujer negra y estoy dominante
por ende soy gay debo ser lesbiana
porque dicen eso a qué se refieren
cuando dicen parece ser lesbiana que
quieren decir cómo se ve una lesbiana
ah
[Música]
den un paso adelante si están de acuerdo
es normal que las mujeres heterosexuales
se sientan atraídas por otras mujeres
si es completamente normal somos
atractivas todas somos lindas sensuales
y ardientes así que la atracción es
totalmente a lo largo de mi vida he
tenido un par de citas con mujeres las
mujeres somos atractivas y hermosas me
ha pasado que como tuve una relación
duradera con un hombre que se criticó
mucho para mí las personas me han dicho
que debería identificarme como bisexual
me parece interesante porque en lo
personal quedarte con una etiqueta es no
tanto una etiqueta sino algo que te
identifica y que eliges por ti mismo
y puedes detenerte cuando quieras no
creo que es un viaje y en mi caso me
detuve en lesbiana y me quedaré aquí sin
miedo
tengo una pregunta relacionada and
pensando en mujeres mientras se
masturban sí porque somos atractivas en
mi caso una mujer heterosexual no
siempre me gusta la puedo decir la
palabra con pe si pornografía no siempre
me gusta la pornografía heterosexual y
hay estudios que te mostraron que las
mujeres en general lesbianas o no ven
más porno homosexual porque están viendo
a una mujer recibir placer y eso para mí
la pornografía homosexual me da una
sensación de placer diferente a la que
suelo obtener con la heterosexual tiene
sentido en mi caso descubrí la
pornografía a los 17 y cuando la vi dije
el sexo es para el hombre porque así la
como se ve es solo para que él se sienta
bien yo no podía entender que se suponía
que la mujer también debía sentir algo
por eso comparto tu opinión
sí sí
hola me llamo sara y soy heterosexual he
sentido atracción física por algunas
mujeres una vez me gusta una chica pero
no escaló a nada fue algo rápido además
de eso nunca he pensado en involucrarme
con mujeres ni sexual ni románticamente
chica femenina y [ __ ] son términos
problemáticos
en mi caso yo era la única niña en las
fiestas de niños siempre porque todos
mis amigos eran niños y la gente decía o
claire parece un niño además no era una
niña de vestidos y quería hacer cosas
que solían hacer los niños por eso todos
me llamaban así a ese término me impidió
entender mi sexualidad por un tiempo en
la adolescencia era mucho más femenina
usaba estos vestidos de princesa con tul
y brillo y otros amaba pero me empezaron
a decir chica femenina y comentaban no
puede ser gay si se ve así creo que es
difícil decirle a alguien lo que
realmente viene es lo único que
consideró que podría ser problemático
porque a ti te afecto es ahí cuando
empieza a ser un problema no puedes
etiquetar a alguien deben hacerlo ellos
mismos etiquetarte a ti mismo está bien
pero hacérselo a alguien más no es bueno
hola me llamo claire tengo 23 y soy
lesbiana
la heteronormativa es un problema porque
creces en un mundo donde se asume que
eres heterosexual es lo que me pasó a mí
muchos crecimos viendo sólo personajes
heterosexuales y cultura heterosexual en
todos los medios pensaba que todos mis
sentimientos eran malos y los reprimir
por mucho tiempo por eso creo que la
heteronormativa es un problema en la
sociedad y que deberíamos tener más
modelos a seguir queer en todos los
espacios
creo que debemos reconocer que hay
diferencia entre ser mujer y ser
femenina me siento como mujer pero me
represento de forma masculina y debo
decir que ser femenina tiene ciertas
cualidades emocionales y ser masculina
tiene otras si muchos esperan que todas
seamos sumisas creen que no hay otra
manera porque como somos mujeres
automáticamente debemos ejercer ese rol
yo soy muy dominante considero que mi
forma de presentarme al mundo es muy
dominante por eso los hombres en
específico suelen sugerir que como soy
una mujer negra y soy dominante por ende
soy gay
debo ser ellos deben hacerles bien nuevo
ser lesbiana porque dicen eso a qué se
refieren cuando dicen parece ser
lesbiana que quieren decir cómo se ve
una lesbiana no tenemos una blue todas
somos diferentes es la verdad cuando le
dije a mi familia que era lesbiana mi
mamá me preguntó si eres lesbiana porque
te gustan las mujeres que parecen
hombres
la forma en la que se visten no importa
para nada eso es una decisión personal
quería hacerles a todas una pregunta
ustedes se consideran chicas femeninas o
marimachas creo que me presento de forma
más femenina pero en mi interior soy
algo masculina porque actuó de cierta
manera como un hombre uso la lógica soy
fuerte y no me gusta decir cómo me
siento aunque me vea femenina en el
exterior pero creo que todas estas
etiquetas hacen que sea más difícil para
mí salir y conocer a otras chicas si
hago contacto visual no suelen entender
por qué las veo el objetivo del
patriarcado es dividir a las mujeres y
conquistar las ese es su plan quieren
que peleemos entre nosotros y que
compitamos siempre por unos l es como un
papel creo que mi intención es ver yo me
morí otras mujeres siempre pero a veces
pienso porque ella me está mirando acaso
no le agradó me está juzgando tal vez
solo le gustó y piensa que soy linda
debería pensar eso la próxima vez
hola soy día y soy heterosexual la
primera vez que vivo caf loca flame
entendí que ese era mi camino si tuve
una fase en la que intenté averiguar si
me gustaban las mujeres pero siempre
terminaba regresando a
hombres me he sentido confundida por mi
orientación sexual
tuve una etapa en mi vida en la que
pensaba que los hombres eran geniales
hasta que me hicieron daño pero mucho
daño así que pensé necesito un descanso
y me pregunte cuál sería mi próximo paso
por eso empecé a salir con chicas como
les dije pero no he encontrado a una
mujer que me haga decir sabes yo me
siento confundida todos los días porque
creo que la sexualidad es tan fluida y
siempre puedes cambiar cómo te
identificas y también siento cierto
apego a la idea de que tal vez todavía
podría llegar a gustarme un hombre o que
podría crear un vínculo como un hombre
sí y hasta identificarme como lesbiana
fue muy difícil porque siento que podría
seguir siendo bisexual ya que he salido
con hombres y porque sé que soy capaz de
lograr que me gusten los hombres así que
no sé si en verdad me gustan los hombres
o si creo que me gustan porque es la
norma la sociedad nos enseñó que la vida
de ensueño se basa en encontrar al
príncipe azul
enamorarse y tener hijos nos dieron más
opciones
yo tenía todo planeado me iba a casar
con un surfista vamos a tener muchos
hijos y será genial pero cuando tuve mi
primera cita en la secundaria sentí que
iba a tomar mi mano en el cine y estaba
emocionada y cuando me tocó hice esto mi
cuerpo lo supo antes que yo el término
queer no se usaba en esa época el
término despectivo era gay eso es gay y
era un insulto así que pensaba no soy
gay no me insulten tiempo después conocí
los términos queer gay lesbiana y logré
entender todo mucho mejor creo que la
familia tiene un papel importante estuve
casada con un hombre por seis años para
mí fue difícil reunir el valor para
salir del closet porque vengo de un
hogar latino bastante estricto intenté
obligarme por mucho tiempo a estar en
una relación heterosexual por el bien de
mi familia y porque pensaba que no
podría tener una relación buena con
alguna mujer
creo que esa confusión es bastante
normal para todos diría el elemento más
confuso en mi caso fue el aspecto sexual
de mi orientación sexual de hecho porque
tuve una relación con un hombre por 7
años y con el tiempo aprendí que nuestra
dinámica cuando teníamos relaciones
sexuales era la dinámica que yo quería
pero no me gustaba el rol que tenía en
ella cuando empecé a presentarme al
mundo de forma más masculina un día una
persona que no recuerdo me miró a los
ojos y me dijo las mujeres como tú no
consiguieron un hombre por eso quieren
ser uno me sentí insultado
me llamo rachel y me identifico como
lesbiana la hetero normal
de disciplina que subyuga a las personas
es un gran problema en la actualidad en
especial porque invita a las mujeres a
pensar que deben tener un nombre o como
me dijeron a mí convertirme en uno no
significa que la heterosexualidad es un
problema no está mal que las personas
sean heterosexuales y tampoco está mal
ser gay o lesbiana
enma en mi caso solo he tenido
relaciones sexuales con hombres no con
mujeres así que no he tenido ninguna
experiencia similar a las de ustedes
pero si en algún momento decidiera
tenerla con mujeres no usaría una
etiqueta la razón por la que no estoy de
acuerdo
con la frase es porque hay ciertas cosas
que no me gusta explicar a nadie esta es
una de ellas no tengo por qué explicar
con quién me voy a casar no tengo por
qué explicar qué pasa en mi habitación
no tengo por qué explicar nada me gustan
las mujeres he salido con ellas he hecho
cosas con ellas igual con los hombres
pero no siento necesario etiquetarme
como algo solo para poder encajar en una
categoría siempre he querido saber algo
por qué es tan importante identificarse
en una categoría específica y salir del
closet de donde nace la necesidad de
decirle al mundo quién es en lo personal
solo había visto el lado heterosexual de
la vida no me sentía igual al resto de
mis amigas sentí que algo andaba mal
conmigo desde la escuela hasta la
universidad
quería decepcionar a mi familia ni que
pensaran mal de mí las etiquetas son un
tema muy personal para mí fue muy útil
encontrar a personas que describieran
cómo me sentí por tanto tiempo sé que no
entiendes por qué es tan importante
salir del closet pero imagina estar en
un closet está oscuro estás solo no
tienes a nadie a quien decirle cómo te
sientes además la representación es
importante en mi hogar crecí con un papá
y una mamá luego se separaron y ahora mi
mamá está casada con una mujer fueron la
primera pareja negra del mismo sexo en
la portada de la revista essence siento
que la representación es importante y si
no hubiese ninguna etiqueta cómo se
vería a este mundo no habría comunidad
siento que si las etiquetas no
existieran
lamentablemente muchas personas
seguirían en el closet en la oscuridad
hola soy amy y soy lesbiana me escondí
por mucho tiempo porque vengo de un
hogar bastante estricto debido a eso
me obligué a estar en una relación
heterosexual y hasta llegué a casarme
con esta persona después de ignorar a mi
esposo por un año me di cuenta que no
podía seguir así esa no era la vida que
yo quería y tampoco lo que deseaba vivir
para mi futuro
creo que los roles de género
tradicionales son importantes
espera
hasta cierto punto son importantes si un
hombre saliera con una mujer y decidiera
en casarse se esperaría que el hombre
provea y que la mujer se quede en casa o
trabaje y se encargue de criar a los
niños si los roles de género no
existieran como como fulana haría el
mundo dije que estoy de acuerdo porque
la palabra rol está ahí por un motivo un
rol es una función no deberíamos
naturalizar los roles de género ni
establecer que las mujeres tienen este y
los hombres del otro porque tu cuerpo no
define tu destino solo creo que podrían
ser una herramienta para organizar
nuestras vidas además hay que reconocer
que no podemos deshacernos de las
diferencias de género así que
reconocerlas y analizarlas de forma
crítica es lo importante creo que
estamos en una época donde queremos
destruir estructuras cuyos motivos de
creación no hemos comprendido por
completo es importante entender que
necesitamos algún limbo de estructura
pero dicha estructura debería estables
porque nací con ciertos genitales debo
cumplir un rol no lo sea depende de la
sociedad a la que pertenezca no quiero
hacerlo absolutamente todo no quiero por
eso los roles de género son importantes
así se le asignan ciertas tareas a cada
persona y me parece que eso está bien
soy marcha y soy heterosexual siento que
muchas de nuestras decisiones vienen de
una pre programación en mi caso nació en
jamaica y allá ser homosexual es
imposible no se hace sólo hay un camino
ser heterosexual no hay nada más por eso
parte de mi decisión viene de mi crianza
pero también por las experiencias
personales que me ayudaron a confirmar
que este es el camino que yo quiero
seguir
mi novia y yo no tenemos roles de género
para nada ambas nos encargamos de todo y
considero que nos ha funcionado viven
juntas ah no eso marca la diferencia
aunque tenemos tres semanas viviendo
juntas podría cambiar a medida que
convivan más si no entiendo por qué
ciertas responsabilidades se le deberían
asignar a un género en específico crecí
con dos mamás y nunca dije oh esta es mi
mamá y esta es mi papá ambas de la misma
más y las dos trabajaban así que me
lanzaron a la guardería algo que suelen
hacer los papás y hablamos de roles de
género y pensar que debe existir un
balance y compartir responsabilidad es
decir que los roles de género son
importantes no significa que deberían
emplearse porque no creo que deberían
imponerse a nadie en todo depende de
cuánta carga quieras llevar no deberían
imponérsele a nadie mencionaste algo de
lavar los platos mi ex esposo era quien
se quedaba en casa mientras yo trabajaba
él era el encargado de lavar los platos
y de cocinar
el mundo sería un mejor lugar sin los
hombres
desde el punto de vista histórico los
hombres fueron quienes iniciaron las
guerras
crearon un lugar donde las mujeres no
tenemos el mismo respeto o capacidad de
ser escuchadas y vistas creo que sería
más fácil para mí que no existieran
porque muchas veces los hombres no
entienden que puedo ser una mujer que no
sueña estar con un hombre algunos
quieren cambiarme o piensan que la
heterosexualidad es la única opción hola
me llamo jamie y me identifico como
lesbiana estoy segura porque sé que soy
capaz de estar con hombres me parecen
atractivos y sé que puedo tener
relaciones sexuales con ellos pero en lo
romántico siento que nunca podré
conectarme con ellos
el poder de los hombres puede llegar a
ser muy extremo lo estamos viviendo hoy
en día los hombres blancos ancianos
quieren controlar los cuerpos de las
mujeres pero opino que todavía los
necesitamos porque tener otra
perspectiva siempre es bueno si me
cuesta responder a esta pregunta porque
la única persona que me ha golpeado fue
una lesbiana femenina también he
experimentado avances sexuales no
deseados de parte de hombres y fue
bastante malo pero mi peor trauma hasta
ahora lo causó una mujer no sería un
mejor lugar sin los hombres pero sí creo
que ellos deberían educarse un poco más
la forma en que los chicos tratan a las
chicas desde la escuela no está bien si
te molestas porque le gustas si hablan
de tu cabello estoy de acuerdo
deberíamos abolir a los hombres pero sí
creo que deberíamos nivelarnos siento
que llegamos a este punto debido a todas
las cosas que han hecho los hombres a lo
largo de nuestra historia ahora tienen
un poder mucho mayor al que podríamos
alcanzar todas las mujeres pero a pesar
de eso somos quiénes somos gracias a lo
que hemos atravesado
[Música]
y